herzlich willkommen zu einem spiel auf
das wir alle lange gewartet haben es hat
sehr lange in der planung und ist toll
herzlich willkommen zum spiel des jahres
dieses spiel des jahres ist nichts
anderes als getrackt
am lg flirt
alles klar alles klar in diesem spiel
darum dass ich schön
man spiele ganz normal fliegen hat allah
einige zusatzeffekte was sie so macht so
scheiße ich weiß ja nicht was man high
score ist weil hier die ganze so eine
scheiße eingeflogen kommt wie pussy dies
freut sich das ganze ist quasi happy
bird mit
ich glaube das erklärt sich von selbst
mein highscore 37 den versuche ich jetzt
auf jeden fall mal zu knacken
das hat super geklappt jetzt gerade und
ich weiß gar nicht mehr was ist mit den
nachbarn born hört man die sind übel
anbohren können wir aufhören
so früh morgens muss man nicht anfangen
zu bohren ignoriert das bohren jetzt am
besten mittag und allgemein ist es halt
in letzter zeit würde steigen
rottweil ich hab gerade einfach 118 als
highschool reg dich nicht auf luca wir
spielen ganz friedliches spiel und
weiter ich komme dass du was du sagen
weil dann wieder alles ausrastet wir mit
diesem typen und mitten im dorf da unten
und dann habe ich auch noch eine mütze
hoffen jetzt schon wieder ganztags was
soll das nehmen sie betrank ich glaube
ich bin irgendwie echten falschen film
gelandet bei diesem spiel aber ich bin
ja auch ein passender major player also
da wurde ja auch gar nicht sagen dass
ich mich jetzt nicht auskennen ich weiß
natürlich komplett genau was ich mich
eingelassen haben ich weiß was ich
vorhin sagen wollte ich bin dabei
warum es ist acht uhr versteht ihren
hass was sich vorher sagen wollte war
dass ich mir komplett neues equipment
wahrscheinlich hier verliere ich am
anfang das komplette spiele scheiße und
da war einfach
haltet euch schlau ich bin einfach mein
video aufnehmen
na was ich noch mal sagen wollte war ich
werde mir komplett neues micro neue
kabel neuen gelenkarm neues audio
interface ich werde mir alles nachholen
weil meine ganzen sache nicht gerade
aufnehme sind alle schon 45 jahre alt
deswegen habe ich
wenn ich die noch einmal hören hören
dann mach ich hier scheint ihn nicht zu
jucken ich werde mir komplett neues
equipment holen wir meinen ganze schon
so übels alt ist und mittlerweile liegt
halt nicht mehr darin dass die
einstellungen nicht stimmen dass es
teilweise nicht mal raus oder brummt
oder so sondern einfach weil die sachen
so alt sind und mittlerweile irgendwie
so viel staub drin ist und die kabel
teilweise die knicks sind kaputt ich es
halt immer nur von anderen youtube mit
so hey ich hab schon wieder neuen pc und
her ich zeige euch im raucherzimmer und
haye schon wieder so tolles equipment
und alles kostet milliarden euros und
ich nehme mit meiner alten scheiße auf
dann fühle ich mich dann schon so ein
bisschen schlecht was die qualität
angeht dazu spiele ich noch so ein spiel
wie mlg flat world und nehmen an meine
nachbarn bohren wie sonst was aber noch
einen kanal wenn ihr tolles gaming sehen
wollt dann geht's mit oder tom macht das
sehr gut oder sarrazin könnte bei den
vorbeischauen wenn ihr seht ihr scheiße
ich habe jetzt hier gerade wirklich fünf
minuten gewartet und geschaut ob die
nebenan mal irgendwie langsam aufhören
zu bohren aber es freut mich juckt die
etwa nicht dass sie noch andere leute
wohnen da ich jetzt übrigen so lange
gewartet da weil ich mittlerweile schon
einen stopp von 360 tatsächlich
vielleicht sollte ich öfters einmal
nicht reden und versuchen gut zu sein
wir haben die 400 geknackt freunde
das ist echt übel und fassbar als übel
und fassbar luca wahrscheinlich ist es
übel und fassbar oder nein ich bin tot
wir haben als fucking score 492 dass
videos vorbei oder aufzubauen
wenn euch das video hier gefallen hat
und ihr euch denkt acht kommen auch wenn
die nachbarn den mann an bord auch wenn
die qualität scheiße und auch wenn das
spiel scheiße ist dann
ist ein berechtigter grund daumen runter
zu geben eigentlich wenn ihr euch
trotzdem denkt ach der der kalender der
mittlerweile vierte tür die ich beim
öffnen komplett demoliert habe und
hintertür 12 haben wir schon wieder nur
so ein dummes kleid naja freunde und
freundinnen da draußen schenkt mir
daumen hoch tschüss
und klickt auf die werbung und kauft
mein merchandise nick oft nicht
ausverkauft und das wieder da